Each year, some countries offer their hours in spring, just to return them
Back in the fall. For most of the world they do not
Involved in this strange manipulation of clocks - this manipulation seems strange. If so
Is the reason behind it? The main idea, proposed by George Hudson,
They were giving people more sunlight during the summer. Sure, it is important to note that change
The clock does not make more sunlight - that's how physics works.
But with hours offered for one hour, and for all other humanitarian activities,
The sun will look like it is shining and late. The time in which clocks are made
Called daylight saving time, the rest of the year is called normal time.
This change gives people more time to enjoy the sunshine and fun atmosphere
Summer after working time. Hudson specifically wanted more sunlight to spend
Time to increase his collection of insects. When winter approaches, the hours are back
Assuming that people would not want to spend much time abroad.
But winter does not affect all people in this way.
If you live in the Kahuai tropical region, you do not need to worry about the seasons of the year
Because, overall, they do not occur. Every day, throughout the year, is a beautiful day shining
For example, Christmas Day would be a nice day to go to the beach like any other day. Therefore, Hawaiian is Yp] n
Two states ignore daylight saving time.
But the more you move away from the squalor of equanimity, the greater the impact of the seasons
The winter will be colder and darker, and summer time will be of great value to the population
That region. So it is not surprising that the more the state is removed from the equator
The more they are used for daylight saving time. Hudson proposed his idea at Wellington in 1895
But it did not meet with approval, and was surprised until 1916 when Germany became the first country
It works in daylight saving time. Although the Germans were the industry
Less enthusiastic about catching butterflies on a lovely summer evening than their enthusiasm
To provide coal for their military equipment. The Germans thought it was daylight saving time
It will save energy. The explanation is that this will encourage people to stay abroad longer during
During the summer, thereby reducing the use of industrial lighting. It seems logical and successful
Then in the organized society of the last century, but is there any benefit in modern times?
Surprisingly, this is a difficult question
answer to. For example, one hopes for the greatest human inventions:
air conditioner. The magic box that has made unmanned places of our world
Areas where they are likely to live. But heat removal from your home is not
A single conditioner is equivalent to the operation of twelve light bulbs (tungsten).
If people got more sunlight, they did not take advantage of it
To spend time, daylight saving time will save rather than provide electricity.
Especially in the area of ​​(Phoenix)
Where the mean temperature is 107 and the highest score is 122, during the summer.
If you suggested that a resident of Arizona offer their hours to get more sun brightness,
I will be ashamed of you. More sun and an increase in electricity bills is another thing he wants!
That explains why Arizona is the second state that does not change its hours.
Another problem when trying to study daylight saving time is rapid changes in technology
and electrical use. And as technology gets better and better and
better more electricity is dedicated to things that are not light bulbs.
And the lure of a hot, sweaty, mosquito-filled day outside is less appealing than technological
entertainments and climate-controlled comfort inside.
Also the horrifically energy-efficient tungsten light bulbs that have remained unchanged
for a century are giving way to CFLs and LEDs - greatly reducing the amount of energy
required to light a room. So, even assuming that DST is effective, it's
probably less effective with every with every passing year.
The bottom line is while some studies say DST costs more electricity and others say
it saves electricity, the one thing they agree on is the effect size: not 20% or 10% but
1% or less, which, in the United States, works out to be about $ 4 per household.
$ 4 saved or spent on electricity over an entire year is not really a huge deal either way.
So the question now becomes the hassle of switching the clocks twice a year worth
it? The most obvious trouble comes from sleep
depravation - an already common problem in the western world that DST makes measurably
worse. With time-tracking software we can actually
see that people are less productive the week after the clock changes. This comes with huge
associated costs. To make things worse, most countries take
away that hour of sleep on a Monday morning. Sleep depravation can lead to heart attacks
and suicides and the Daylight Saving Time Monday has a higher than normal spike in both.
Other troubles come from scheduling meetings across time zones.
Let's say that your trying to plan a three-way conference between New York, London and Sydney
- not an easy thing to do under the best of circumstances but made extra difficult
when they do not agree on when daylight saving time should start and end.
In the spring, Sydney is 11 hours ahead of London and New York is five hours behind.
But then New York is the first to enter Daylight Saving Time and moves its clock forward an
hour. Two weeks later London does the same. In one more week, Sydney, being on the opposite
side of the world, leaves daylight saving time and moves its clock back an hour.
So in the space of three weeks New York is five hours behind London, then four hours
and then five hours again. And Sydney is either 11, 10 or 9 nine hours from London and 16,
15 or 14 hours from New York. And this whole crazy thing happens again in
reverse six months later. Back in the dark ages, this might not have
mattered so much but in the modern, interconnected world planning international meetings happens
1,000s and 1,000s of times daily - shifting and inconsistent time zones is not doing
netizens any favors. And, to make matters worse, countries are not
even consistent about daylight saving time within their own borders.
Brazil has daylight saving time, but only if you live in the south. Canada has it too,
but not Saskatchewan. Most of Oz does DST, but not Western Australia, The Northern Territory
Egypt Queensland. And, of course, the United States does have
DST, unless you live in Puerto Rico, the Virgin Islands, American Samoa, Guam, the Northern
Marianas Islands or, as mentioned before Hawaii and Arizona.
But Arizona is not even consistent within itself.
While Arizona ignores DST, the Navaho Nation inside of Arizona follows it.
Inside of the Navaho Nation is the Hopi Reservation which, like Arizona, ignores daylight saving
time. Going deer, inside of the Hopi Reservation
is another part of the Navaho Nation which does follow daylight saving time.
And finally there is also part of the Hopi Reservation elsewhere in the Navaho Nation
which does not. So driving across this hundred-mile stretch
would technically necessitate seven clock changes which is insane.
While this is an unusual local oddity here is a map showing the different daylight saving
and time zone rules in all their complicated glory - it's a huge mess and constantly
needs updating as countries change their laws. Which is why it should not be surprising
that even our digital gadgets can not keep the time straight occasionally.
So to review: daylight saving time gives more sunlight in the summer after work, which,
depending on where you live might be an advantage - or not.
And it may (or may not) save electricity but one thing is for sure, it's guaranteed to
make something that should be simple, keeping track of time, quite complicated - which
is why when it comes time to change the clocks is always a debate about whether or not we
should.ch